Thank you everybody.
Well, it's exciting to see at least some people
stayed around for a Thursday session.
I love it. This is like the perfect day and time
because it actually allows me to try out some new material,
maybe set land some jokes, land some
commentary. It's gonna be fantastic.
So instead of doing slides and
boring you with more slides, what I thought I'd do
is walk you through a journey
of what's happening and why we created
these solutions.
Let's take ourselves back, put ourselves as
a producer for a sports league,
as an executive for a sports league.
What is one of the fundamental problems that they have?
And we've heard it over and over again.
They have tons and tons of footage.
How do you actually use all of your footage? How
do you make and monetize that as they go forward?
How do you coalesce those across MAMM systems?
MAMs are media asset management platforms.
How do you use your S3 archives effectively?
And then how do you bring and
start to talk about how you monetize that as you go
forward
and like many organizations they struggle
with how to break down those content silos
to create monetization and opportunities
to create opportunities and for their
businesses to grow.
Nothing was talking to each other. Nothing actually moves
together, and at the same time,
they can't even see how they use their
content effectively.
So this creates a big problem
and when we ask that question what if
what if your content was connected?
What if your solutions were
connected with each other? What if your content
had context in order to make it forward
and how do we break down the barriers of simplicity,
intelligence and create value across our
ecosystem?
So let's step back and walk through
what that journey would look like.
So with all that decades of footage and archived
assets, one of the biggest challenges and problems is
how do you move that all into a cloud archive? How
do you move it into a storage mechanism?
It's very difficult and it's very expensive,
so there's a barrier right there.
But more importantly,
how do you organize that data from
what you're looking at from metadata?
Metadata is a fancy word for tagging, and
how do you look at that from
disparate information sources?
When I was at other companies we would have hard drives
filled with content.
They'd be like Pokemon cards, you'd actually distribute
and deliver out to everybody else.
Nobody know where anything was, was there.
The problem is
once you look at that,
you can't ask the question of
how do I create a play, how do I create a, create
content, how do I create excitement with
that footage because it's gonna take
345 hours to
find that particular type of content.
You can't launch a new fan experience. You heard from the
demo the first day,
the keynote the first day, condo.
How do you tie your fans to your experience, to your
content, to your creators?
It's a big opportunity and it's a missed
opportunity that they can stop and they can't
sell their archives and their footage.
It's called content chaos.
But we wanna actually start to simplify
and transform that as we go forward
and what that looks like
is building that central
content repository of that brain
we actually look at how we take and simplify
the fragmented content and the disconnected assets
that are looking at the left hand side,
create pipelines and agents to
understand what is actually that
content doing,
what agents you need to kick off and how you need to
process that. And then all the way on
the left hand side as you're looking at the screen,
you're actually getting that content intelligence, that
unified knowledge of how your
content and how your information is put together.
What this provides for you is it
provides for you the ability
to unify and execute your content.
So let's walk through these individual stages,
and I'll talk through each of them
individually.
Think about ingest.
Whether you're an HR department, whether you're a medical
records company,
whether you're looking at sports content and
footage that I talked about earlier.
You need to figure out where your content is. You need
to ingest that, and you wanna do it without
humans because more humans are involved,
the more error, the more challenges you get with
your individual types of content.
So the ingest allows you to structure your
content, but more importantly, as I talked about earlier,
build the right pipelines. Are you looking at sports
content? Are you looking at flat files? Are you looking at
spreadsheets?
How do I tie them all together and ingest them so the
data has meaning?
The next part is really around the enrichment
and enrichment is a fancy word for how do we
tag and coordinate data,
and this is an area where you want to start to build
your experimentation with your tagging.
And part of the problem is which models do you
use, as you heard from a lot of the sessions here,
we wanna simplify that. So we've built a
simple platform
to allow you to actually bring all of your models
in and start to experiment to see which
ones
produce the right level of content and information that
you need. It's not complex. It's
not easy. It's built from a console, so
you can actually simply start to put models in
and start to leverage that to enrich your data.
They handle all the simple pieces of that
structure. What you get out of
it, going back to my analogy from a sports team,
think about a dunk.
When you see a dunk on, on, on film.
It's just a dunk.
It loses its context. It's, it loses its
contextual awareness.
What we're able to do is now put the con
conte, the content,
the dunk in context of what actually happened.
So the dunk becomes he got the dunked
on who?
What was the defender?
What was the time? What was the scoring position?
How did all those things come together to
create that?
And now you've taken your simple vector
searches and created a multimodal
search to allow you to understand that
content as you go forward.
The last part is activate.
Think about it this way. I talked about a sports
team, but I'm gonna draw the analogy to a large brand
or retailer.
You work with them. It takes 39 weeks to
put together an overall marketing campaign
as you look at that.
Take care. Bye bye.
It's OK when you want to activate it.
So now you take and compress that 39
weeks by being able to find that content,
activate that content effectively, while
allowing your creative studios and creative authors
to still be able to use and leverage that
content as it goes forward.
Again, what we did is we didn't make things
harder.
We used AI and the agents to simplify
and uplift their workflow and their processes
to make it simpler, easier and effective
for them to work.
How this actually happens, if you think about it from a technical
thing, remember that dunk that I talked to you about.
Now we've built a knowledge graph. Amazon
has really great platforms with their Neptune database
to start to put context and information
for how all the content works together.
So that dunk now becomes a web
of meaning.
The player, as we talked about, the defender,
what kind of play, what happened before the play,
what was the scoring opportunity that they looked at?
You're starting to build a method
to understand
how to leverage and use your content effectively.
So now you can ask those complex questions in
the activation phase of show
me every left-handed dunk.
scored in the last 5 years where the player
where the score was tied.
It's not something you can do today
in our complex query system, and it's something
that people and producers for sports
content want to effectively use quickly,
rapidly and easily.
This is a tool that allows you to do that
in a very simplified manner.
What this does is it takes it from 3
hours, 4 hours to a matter of
seconds.
So think, think of yourself,
how you actually use this,
right? You actually have to understand the request
and I'm gonna show you a quick demo hopefully here shortly
of how this all comes together in our platform
as an accelerator.
But you understand the request, you break it down,
you build the right agents as we saw, you could actually
build a word agent. You could build a transcription agent.
It takes that information, breaks it down for you.
It leverages the inert tools
across AWS
to parse that information, pull the right
clips together.
So if you're saying I want 20 seconds' worth of
footage of dunks over the last 3
weeks, it pulls the right footage, it pulls
the right information, and it starts to assemble
that quickly and efficiently.
I call it being
a technical director in a box. It's
not for those big leagues, but if you're
in a break or a commentary section, you
can actually push a button,
get your highlights, get your clips, and start working
forward from that.
So let's, let's take a break here for a second.
Let me show you the power of this because
PowerPoints don't convey the real message of
what's happening.
Right, think about here. This is the platform
that we built. It's an accelerator. It's a
tool that you can use as you go forward.
All of this content could be random content
that you've brought into your archive.
Right, from skateboarding content to
news clipping to footage
and what do you do with this? How do you
process this? How do you use this? How do you add context
to what's going forward?
Oh. So what do you see
here when we process this content for vod
content? You're gonna see a
whole set of information
that you're gonna naturally look at.
You're gonna look at the tags and the information on the left-hand
side. Those are great for simply
doing standard searches.
Now if you want to take it to the next level,
we need to take this and leverage and build context.
So now using those tags and that level
of information.
You can see we're starting to put time frames
to the context to the information
so now you know when a play happened,
who the play happened with,
what was the context around that, and allows
you to start to build complex queries and
information so you can start to assemble your
content and and move very effectively.
Now we didn't do this in a vacuum.
We added a human in the loop so as we
heard earlier, we want to keep training our models
if the information isn't correct by the AI
and the AI that's generated.
You can start to put a human in the loop to start
processing that information,
and then the model will continually learn as
they go forward.
So
what do we have here? Remember I talked about earlier
you wanna do a simple search, right?
So you can actually say fumbles. So
what this tells you is that in my
limited library
what you have is all the fumbles over the
last couple of weeks or months or whatever stored
in your petabytes or terabytes of
content. This helps you a little bit.
It isolates you,
but as a user, you still have to go back and start
to figure out where specific things happen
in that context of that frame. This could
take you hours. It could take you days. It
could take you months.
I remember the first question I asked, can I put together
a 22nd clip
of all the dunks?
This doesn't allow you to do that.
But
with the power of putting the agents together and the
searches together,
right? Allows
you to start to build.
Build together specific moments in time.
So I can't type and talk at the same time.
Thank you.
So what this is actually doing,
remember I talked about the agents, the tools and the power.
So we're actually going back and looking at that clip library
we're building the understanding of the, the architecture
to understand what the query is.
We're pulling out the specific terms,
so Northwestern or fumble and identifying
what you wanna see.
We wanna see. A moment in time of when something
happened and immediately
in 34 seconds
you see the power of what took 3 or 4 hours
naturally displayed leveraging AWS
leveraging the scale that you have
to instantly give you highlights
and clips that allow you to move your business
forward.
Think about the power of how that simplicity
happened and the agents happen to create
and optimize us.
This could work for an HR system. This could work for
a doctor, for example. Think about a
doctor in a medical facility that has tons of
MRIs and information
that they're processing through.
Patient comes in with an abnormal
cardiac arrhythmia.
They can immediately use and leverage the
information, search that, and provide a diagnosis
to prevent potentially a heart attack.
So you can see the power and the
the ease of use that you have here.
And one of the things that we wanted to show by this.
As we've lowered the barrier for using AI.
We've created the simplicity, we've created the
opportunity to start using it and playing
with it. So it's not a fear,
it's a lift to drive your productivity
going forward.
Hopefully that makes sense for everybody that's
looking at this.
Let's go back to our, our, our
content here where we're looking at this going forward.
Right. So we've talked a little bit about the explosion
and information here.
If you think about
how we put this into action and the monetization as
we go forward,
right, real world impacts, what we can
see now is that once you can do this,
you can start to build sponsorship opportunities.
I can go back to a sponsor if you're an
NFL team or if you're a basketball team
and you can basically say,
hey, show me where Michael Jordan did his dunks
displaying
his, his signature red shoes.
I wanna show that or you're creating a brand
awareness moment where something is happening over
a period of time.
Now you can actually simply easily undo that.
I was, I was with a major brand before I came
to Presidio.
What took us 39 weeks to actually put together
an entire campaign can take you 17
hours while still maintaining
the level of creativity and the autonomy
across those content silos to create these
great opportunities
and more importantly.
You can start to take this and associate this
with your CRM systems to create that magic
personalization
that everybody wants when you talk about marketing and in
retail.
So I want to talk about how I want to give
somebody a a specific dunk or a
specific layer of content.
You can do this now effectively and easily
with a simple point and click and do
simple publishing out to Facebook
and TikTok and other social media platforms,
or even put it directly into the subscriber's
inbox or put a push notification
in. It also
allows you to think about coaches on your staff
whether you're a coach internally or a coach
at HR or a coach as an adviser
at a higher ed institution.
You can start to build that pathways to say
how do I understand what a student is doing? Here
are all his class grades. Here's all the
pieces that he's going to here are his test scores
here are all these despair pieces of information.
I'm gonna apply my AI and ML model
to understand which ones are in trouble,
which ones classes they need to look forward to,
and how to help them as they go forward.
So it's not only just a productivity tool for
sports and agents,
but it's a productivity tool across
organizations as you go forward.
And I'll, and I'll start to leave you with.
What is an accelerator? Cause
everybody that comes up to me talks about, well, Presidio is
developing accelerators. What are you actually doing?
We're making it easier as I talked about
we're lowering the bar we're creating simplicity
we're creating the ability for you to start
to pull in information
without having the fear that it goes forward,
right? We take time, right?
So we've built the components, we've built the agents.
You can start to use that to drive faster time
to value.
You can build cost optimization and, and
more importantly,
it specifically aligns with what AWS
is looking for.
So we've started to introduce a managed service. So
if you have the complexity here and you started looking at,
well, I don't know how to deploy this, how do I support this
as we go forward,
we're gonna put a managed service in there for you so
that as changes happen, as things are,
uh, moving forward, you can
get the new models, you can get the new frameworks.
And you can get the new information.
So if this is interesting to you, which it
is to me,
Presidio is a leader as we think
about how we think, think about working with our
SI. We're here to help
drive and augment you as you go forward
and hopefully you can see the power and the simplicity
we provide to your organization.
So if you have more questions, our booth is over in 12:10.
Come visit us. Come learn more about how we're
using accelerators going forward and how we
can help your business accelerate itself.
Thank you very much.